is the head coach of football here in
Southern California the University of
Southern California
he is clay Helton here on the Rich Eisen
show thanks for holding clay we
appreciate the time coach no no thanks
for it thanks for having me what's going
on in your world right now what is
exactly what's at the top of your to-do
list as a head coach in this day and age
well I've got three children by birth
I've got a hundred and ten adopted son
are scattered from Connecticut all the
way to Hawaii so like one is their
health and safety priority one and then
to just keeping them in routine you know
through this you know we're over 60 days
now and to be able to keep them in
routine whether it's their health and
wellness whether it's their academics
whether it's their strength and
conditioning their nutrition and just
keeping their mind engaged in football
is a daylight till dark process and and
it just approached it like just like I
said okay these are my adopted son so
there's I might as well have this phone
and iPad duct-taped to my head I bet you
I bet I bet I bet so you are I'm what
doing video conferencing just like I
guess what we're hearing a lot of NFL
teams are doing are you is that what
you're up to
yeah yeah the product and FaceTime has
been huge in this whole process just to
be able to see kids face to face or
parents face to face to be able to
answer questions for them to be able to
calm fears to be able to give them
information but to again keep them in
routine the NCAA was great to us they
allowed us eight hours of engagement
football wise with our student-athletes
so you know we're having anywhere from
unit meetings the ability to go team
meetings unit meetings position meetings
to continue to grow as players and to
continue to engage their minds and then
using our strength and conditioning
coaches as consultants being able to
being able to give these kids some
equipment strength bands medicine balls
jump ropes just so they can work safely
at home and be able to give them ideas
of what they can do at home in a safe
environment well then how do you in this
day and age though would just zoom
evaluate positions and crucially
obviously the quarterback spot how do
you do something like that
yeah it's
really hard until we get back together
which hopefully you know the way
everything's trending is looking like
it's coming about it's really hard I
mean right now that you're looking at
the mental part of the game and really
our position coaches I have to commend
them are doing a tremendous job of being
able to really grow their life and the
other aspect of this is just trying to
keep kids in physical shape in
nutritional shape and our university has
been great and we're supplying our kids
additional meals pre prep meals and
nutrition packets muscle milks so when
they go home and they get away from that
training table that they're actually
able to get that calorie intake that
they normally would have so it's all
been about keeping kids in the routine
and trying to give them the services
that they need to stay in routine clay
Helton here on the Rich Eisen show when
was the last time you talked to TJ
Daniels coach Daniels when was the last
time you spoke to him I transpose there
and working with his family as he works
through the process you know JT's such a
great kid and a great player and came to
us in the spring and said coach I'd like
to evaluate all my options for 2020 USC
is one of those options and that doors
are being left open for him I'd been
through a process like this last year
would Matt think and work through that
process with them provided an open door
for him to be back we would love to have
JT on our team but he's got a personal
decision that he's going to make and to
make the best decision for himself and I
always believe you know you work with
kids if you treat them like your adopted
sons and be able to work through the
process with them sometimes it works out
sometimes they move on but you're always
there for so between myself and JT we
talk each and every week so when do you
have to make a decision on this from a
Warner you need a decision from him
because I know it's it's just so
difficult man I mean you got enough
going on as you point out with the
number of kids you have biologically and
adopted and and when when this is
actually happen but you also need to
plan as if this is definitely happening
you know
you know I'm getting constant
communication from him but that door
will always be left open for JT he was a
member of our family when I signed a kid
and he does things the right way like JT
has he's been a great team made a great
student a great family member to our own
organization he's always going to be
granted that opportunity now obviously
we'll look for other options as they
come available but JT is always welcome
at USC clay Helton here on the Rich
Eisen show you said that's trending in
the direction of you being able to get
these kids on campus and start
practicing I imagine or something of the
like
what what's giving you the indication
we're trending in that direction well a
couple things you know the NCAA came out
and obviously is now allowing volunteer
workouts on campus across the country
it's going to be up to conferences going
to be up to universities based on where
they are geographically their population
what's going on with the virus in their
situation but it was great to hear
governor Anderson come out the other day
and be able to say he sees pro sports
getting ready to open back up in June
and our university is working tirelessly
as well as all universities across the
country working tirelessly to put safety
measures in place to be able to bring
students back when it is healthy and
safe and those safety measures are in
place so you know I'm very appreciative
to dr. Carol holt in the backbone I mean
they're working daylight till dark mark
to put put these measures in place I
will allow not only our student athletes
but students to come back when it's safe
and but right now there's a lot of
positive energy out there that this
thing is training at the right direction
we're very optimistic about the fall
season and I think we're going to get
even more clarity as the week's
progressed well I spoke to the head
coach of Notre Dame football who you see
across the field every year in Bryan
Kelly he was talking about they're still
working on protocols to deliver to
parents to say this is what we're gonna
do one year
kids are put on a plane from I guess
spots as you point out from Connecticut
all the way to Hawaii where are you on
that from yeah so we're
yeah so we're working through those
safety measures and those protocols and
they're basically would be broken up in
phases and and you know it's also going
to register you know each place is
different because you're going to have
to follow the directives of government
leadership to local and state and
federal so I think it's really based on
where you were at currently with the
virus what geographic you are in are you
a hotspot or not where are you as far as
your local and state government so
everybody's going to be different
meanwhile universities are working as
hard as they can to be able to put those
procedures and those safety measures in
place so when we are granted those
opportunities come back on onto campus
that we are prepared and ready to have
our students back have you become an
expert in public health claim in a way
that you never thought you have - very
much so
and you know just just looking at from a
parent's eyes and to be honest with you
and just like I said I mean I truly
believe I've got 110 adopted sons and
it's not about the X's nose right now
it's those will come into place when
it's time to play game somewhere down
the future it's more about you know
making sure that we've provided a safe
and healthy environment for them to be
able to function in and that's been my
primary worry and I know our
university's primary worry moving
forward here and so you know usually
football coaches I thank you we're
always worried about points and stopping
people in the next game but now it's
about though it is about those safety
measures and being able to whether it's
me practice be together with having a
hundred and ten men that are on a
football team together and how you get
that done and so that's that's been more
the conversations rather than preparing
for a maybe a game come September
October November whatever it might be
well what about the first game starting
in January are you like literally
pushing this season all the way we're
hearing about how the loss of revenue
would
so catastrophic if there's no football
season just pushing it into the spring
are you are you hearing that or
preparing for that too right now well I
think we're really optimistic rush to be
honest with you about about having a
twenty20 football season I don't know
exactly what the start they'd be or what
the structure is but every conversation
that I've had leadership has done the
NSA lead NCAA leadership as well as the
commissioners in their leadership
previous conference is really working
diligently to put together a ton of
different structures to be able from
different start dates two different ways
of season may run and we'll see how this
goes I think we're going to have a lot
more clarity here in about six weeks as
my is my judgment hopefully everything
keeps trending in the right direction
but I think all of us are really
optimistic to be able to have this fall
season and we're got our fingers crossed
we want we're excited about having an
opportunity to be a part of an exciting
Alabama game a great rivalry game like
Notre Dame in the nine game conference
schedule just battling for a conference
championship in the national title so we
are optimistic in that and our NCAA
leadership and and university leadership
and kind of personal leadership will
determine you know where we get to what
that start date is and what that
structure is and emprah coaches we're
going to focus on taking care of our
football team making sure that they're
healthy they're safe and they're
prepared coach appreciate the time have
a great safe weekend and we'll catch you
down the line and hopefully with your
your timing about 4-6 weeks from now
talking about a playing season and a
health protocol that we can all follow
plan that would be great what thank you
rich thanks for the time you got it
that's it clay Hilton USC football head
coach hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here